how long did you book them did you have
you ever been back to aberdeen since the
crash course oh so you literally just
came here went to the crash course and
then straight away boom
ellen just quit uh she just wrangled i'm
not coming back no
so you came to the crash course you
learned you join the e-academy and then
you just quit yeah hey what's up guys
welcome back to my channel in this video
i want you to hear from ashley and ellen
who are financially free they've done it
super super fast through rent to rent
and deal sourcing they flew down all the
way from abu dhabi aberdaby to meet me
and now they've gone through the
training they've implemented it they're
absolutely killing it so i hope you
enjoyed this video i hope you enjoy this
chat this is real life property
investing so smash the like button
subscribe and enjoy the show hey guys
thank you so much for coming down to my
house thank you very much myself thanks
for having us so you've got one of the
most fascinating stories of all winners
on a wednesday stories tell me what
happened at the beginning and how did
this all come into fruition yeah so
basically my whole knowledge of property
was very little um my whole my family
don't really invest in property the
their understanding of getting wealthy
is to buy a house live in it you know
very over time so i thought well
i'm in a job that's well paying and we
can start getting by to let's uh every
year or so so i'll come back after about
a decade with a nice little portfolio
back first so i fall off the best way to
get wealthy and then we stumbled across
you in the uh in the in the uae i
thought well we can you know this is
much faster um so yeah um
so you were kind of like going about it
the slow traditional way working hard
working up the corporate ladder saving
up money putting it into property you're
in abu dhabi what we got did you mean
abu dhabi or how did you guys meet no so
we met about six months before we went
to abu dhabi and ashley was a teacher i
was in london and then i decided to go
out to abu dhabi to teach ash decided to
follow me over there yeah i've quit my
job oh you could jump to go
with with ellen yeah yeah amazing quit
my job and just decided to come over
which was you know all my mates was
that's a terrible idea give you one of
six months and i was like no this is
this is the right thing to do this is
true love
true love okay so you got a teaching job
and you went to be with her and then so
you're in abu dhabi how was that going
it was
it was good it was a nice lifestyle we
were going the golf course we
you know it was tax-free salary so
everything
in that way was good the job was
hard we weren't enjoying it it was
draining it was difficult yeah but
because the salary was so good and the
plan was we're gonna take the money that
we make we're gonna put it towards
buying one or two properties a year
we'll do it for ten years we'll come
back we'll have a portfolio yeah we kept
going and then as ash said he was
watching all your videos and said oh we
can do it much quicker if we just go
back yeah it was the eviction they did
it for me that's the individual i can do
this yeah and then um i knew what was
quick but the crash cars coming up it
was like december 18 i think it was
first
yeah and we'll get to that yeah yeah
yeah so we
just quit and fly over
yeah it was
yeah that was a devastating week
tell us what happened
we we spent
so long trying to get back to the uk
so we knew we had to be back for
december 18th for the crash course i
think because coverts the thing we had
to get the tests and my tests came in we
were in the same taxi to get the tests
so they were going to come in the same
time mine came in ashes didn't yeah and
because we've been watching all your
videos we were in the mindset of
whatever it takes we've got to do this
we're just going to do whatever it takes
so we were ringing like covered like the
testing
all night
yeah non-stop or flight we couldn't make
it because the cover test wasn't in so
we pushed and pushed to get it changed
flights flew over we're like we've done
it we've made it get in the taxi
go on my phone and you put a video up
saying oh please don't remind me hey
what's up my name's samuel lives i had
some really bad news today to be honest
i was truly good so we had um a london
crash course booked we had to cancel it
because the hotel we went the whole lot
of london went to tier three so we had a
backup venue just outside london that
then went into tier three so then we had
a backup to the backup in southampton
a few hours ago
southampton council said sorry you can't
run the event it's too high risk so i
was like oh man we are literally people
driving to southampton if you're one of
those people i'm going to make you up to
your promise really sorry everyone like
you travel far
but the council had changed the rules
so literally you came from freaking
other side of the world
to be at this
one day training program and then you
arrive
finally in england and then you get an
email from me and the team saying i'm
really sorry that it's going virtual and
you know what from my end as well i have
to just apologize but from my end as
well like i was so determined to put
that on but we the council just said you
they changed that because that was when
boris was in out in out oh you can't no
you can't and the council just said you
cannot run the event and i i thought i
don't know i'd have been arrested
probably so i felt terrible um but then
i was getting messages from people like
yourself saying we've flown in yeah
there's quite a few people we've come
from switzerland we've come from
australia and i'm like oh my goodness so
i said well you can tell what what what
what i sent an email out to all the
foreign people what happened yeah so you
basically said you know i appreciate you
coming so far away um you know here's
the post orders that you can come and
come to it personally
so we ended up uh arriving at the little
studio and then we met everyone there we
did it live uh you know we met people at
evans and um you know i was there amanda
and uh yeah we just uh we joined the e
academy from that uh event yeah uh you
know he got us into the
uh you gave us all the knowledge we
needed to do the online training yeah
yeah sorry yeah yeah we just quit with
your youtube videos i think we've done
one course yeah so yeah it feels like
yeah done yeah we've just done that so
we had a little bit of knowledge but not
enough to go full on into property right
yeah yeah so i wanted to see you i
wanted to
you know see you there see it happen and
go okay yeah now now we can fully go for
it but see doing a virtual course
traveling all the way to england to
watch something online is devastating
that's why i said if anyone's traveled
overseas come down meet me in person at
the studio watch it live um which we did
we met in person you were really weird
because i was like
so i was massively starstruck because i
just seen you as this big celebrity and
you came over to me and said you know
with the camera how do you feel how did
you feel sorry when the course was
cancelled now i was just like oh yeah it
was great
and then in my head i was like wait what
did you just say
yeah
how did you feel when i invited you i
think that's what i thought i heard but
because i was like so starstruck um i
just blurted them out and i went oh well
that's not being used
so you joined the academy you went
through all of the online training
programs
how was that brilliant yeah so
the dsm was huge for me as well as the
renter end and the sa one yeah um to get
me started with your fun uh rent events
and actually using them as an sa
properly yeah um obviously deal selling
was brilliant for you know what to say
to investors how to build an investor
list and then the brr one was really
important as well because almost
everything needs some kind of refurb
yeah so getting a refill right talking
to builders organizing builders was
really useful yeah they were just good
because it's so step by step here's one
video if you don't understand it watch
it again
it's not a long
video where you think i don't know what
i've just learned here it's just step by
step by step by step yeah
it's really handheld yeah and and you
went through the rent to rent
accelerator yeah that was your favorite
course i love that one yeah that's
what's really like i found the most
interesting
find and rent to rent and
i think my favorite part's always been
when you do them up and you stage them
you can just follow step by step exactly
how to do it and i found that i watched
the videos and then
i didn't implement it straight away i
just watched them and went okay i can do
this and then when i went back
and saw what i'm going to do exactly
what he says to do
that's when i got my renter in so great
so i'm really excited about learning the
action steps that you've done the
results that you've got and what's
happened because you both now
financially free yeah you've achieved it
all in a matter of months which is
incredible really fast uh have you quit
your job known haberdabbie yeah
so you've quit your high paid job in abu
dhabi yeah officially done officially
yet and what about yourself are you
full-time in property yep full-time
property so you're both now full-time
property investors
no job but just business owners now
which is incredible so talk me through
your first deal and how it happened and
also the struggle potentially whatever
what you know just give you the the
warts and all what happened and how did
you get your first deal yeah so the
first one was we were we just come over
for you know the crash course and then
we were on this big bus and then we
realized we have no car or anything to
get anywhere
so in the first like week or so we was
just struggling to get a car because uh
how did it take so long
if you're just trying to find a reliable
car that was actually decent and gonna
get us from a to b yeah yeah how long
did you book them did you have you ever
been back to aberdeen since the crash
course
oh so you literally just came here went
to the crash course and then
so you came to the crash course you
learned you joined the e academy and
then you just quit yeah it was a
terrible idea uh i wouldn't advise
anyone to do it i'm only pretending that
i remember you telling me that on the
shanghai five mastermind session and uh
well what happened so i was really
excited i was like samuel uh you know
he's like able to share yes uh you know
i've quit my job he's amazing uh how
many deals you sold i was like none and
you went oh so you didn't rent a rent i
was like no and then you went
okay next person
that's a terrible idea yeah i was like i
can't advocate that yeah what you've
quit your job but you've not got any
deals i was like oh jeez yes oh sorry
i've missed a big step actually i've
completely forgot so um you know the
only reason we were able to quit our
jobs with nothing is because i was
staying at my mom's house right um
and i literally there was no extra room
i moved out a long time ago i've been
moving that house like four or five
years now so i came back yeah more quit
my job and she was a terrible idea as
well um but wonder why yes
everyone is a terrible idea um so
basically we had a little mattress
behind the couch that every night i'd
pull out and put on the living room
floor oh no i could do it all you know
what though it's so funny but it's so
hard because if you hadn't quit your job
if you'd have gone back to abu dhabi
it would have been quite difficult from
overseas
to to grow
it's alright if you've got money and you
just want to invest in property but
wanting to do these creative strategies
like rent to rents and we've been really
hard from abu dhabi so you kind of had
to make an all or nothing choice yeah
i wouldn't encourage people to quit
their job but you did it so you quit
your job you're sleeping on your mum's
pull out mattress
at home um i know as well and then you
said that that first rent to rent um
before you'd gone on the actual proper
rental event training you were
struggling to get a deal what was
happening
i think
one i was contacting the wrong people i
was focusing too much on if an agent i
was running an estate agent and they
were saying no
and i'd ask more questions rather than
just realize that's not going to work
and i wasn't following the script so i
was sending these big paragraphs
asking about it and i think they were
just looking going spam no
i don't want to deal with that right but
you thought you were putting together an
articulate explanation
yeah i thought i was sending them a good
message explaining what i wanted or how
i can help them and then i looked at the
script
and i said to you didn't i i'm just
gonna go exactly what samuel says to do
i'm gonna go step by step
i just i sent it in messages at first
asking each question
and then
i remember i mentioned that it was going
to be a company let
and i thought that's it she's going to
say no now everyone else says no that's
the end and i put at the bottom
i can visit on friday i can view it on
friday or sunday when works
right i was like straight in there at
the same time and she she came back like
9 p.m that night saying yeah tomorrow at
9am i can show you around
i thought i can't believe it's actually
i know that's only the first step we
still have to speak to them but i was
still shocked that she just said yeah to
us even going yeah and then we went
spoke to her
told us
well we've tried to find out how we
could help her so she didn't have an
issue with tenants
she'd always been able to put someone in
but she didn't live near the property
she lived about an hour away yeah yeah
so the property in new york she lives in
leaves leads yeah so she wanted like the
easiest way to rent it out no problem so
yeah when we're saying oh yeah
start out management sort out any little
problems for you oh me how long do you
want five years yeah perfect there you
go right yeah she wanted someone longer
than one year because she kept enrolling
contracts with like uh students so one
year one year one year and um so when we
offered like a five year or three year
she was like that was great yeah
so you took a five-year contract we we
encouraged to take a shot a year because
it would be better for her right so we
thought it would be great for us to take
five years but you know you don't want
to be locked into a five-year contract
when you've never done this before no
it's like take a free yeah let's see how
we do if you like it we'll continue yeah
so we've had her best at uh so three
year contract how much are you paying
you're in rent
750. that doesn't sound a lot for a york
property so it's discounted yeah yeah
and you've already got a tenant in there
or guests in there so it's still in
refurb we've just come from the property
and
so the management came to have a look um
around the property so you'll see what
we've done in the place if we show up
before and after she's like i love it i
know exactly who i can get in here and
now we've got two months yeah she came
round we said oh we'll just show you as
we're going through it because we are
you know painting the walls we've done a
bit of a new kitchen getting a new
culture but we'll show you so you can
see how it's going to be and she left
and as she left she just went i know
exactly who i'm going to put in here
because they've got a lot of contractors
that's why we picked them yeah because
she has too many contractors and not
enough places that's great so does that
confirm that they're going to be moving
in yeah so it's um
this sunday yes saturday sorry so
they're moving in this weekend yeah how
much are they paying you're paying 750.
yep two grand
so the profit on that and that's fixed
for two months yeah i mean normally with
service accommodation you've got people
coming in for a couple nights a couple
weeks like a couple months what kind of
profit margins are you going to get from
that then so when you take everything
off management the clean um i think it's
685. yeah very good very solid it's
funny because we didn't think we'd be in
this situation where she rang us and she
said i've got someone
two grand i'm like let me just wake it
up on the calculator we take everything
off what's my profit
and she goes i know it's quite low
because we could get higher but i'm just
thinking it's two months you know
straight in there the money will be in
your bank do you want to take it and i
turned to ash and i said do we do we
take it or do we go for the holiday
lights yeah try and get the other three
nights four nights in there yeah and
then we stopped and we thought
i'm actually considering turning down
685 because it could make more i did not
think i'd be in a position where i was
saying oh no i don't want that money
from you actually i think i'm gonna
yeah and get more it's crazy
yeah it is
and it means that as well i mean that's
fixed for two months but it'll probably
be more like a thousand pounds profit
once you've got short stay let's in
there yeah but it's nice to have a fixed
tumor of contracts so when to rent then
when did you first
kind of come across this and understand
what it even is and what it means
because there might be some people
watching are confused right now like
what how does it work when did you first
understand what it is and decide you
wanted to do that with me it was um in
the uae i was watching the videos and
i've seen you run around i was trying to
explain to people because that sounds
like a great idea i mean a first one
this must be illegal
and then uh i was telling my mum and my
brother uh
i was talking about coming home and
doing it
and uh my mom was like that's illegal
there's no way that that could be done
but then obviously
we just fold um full course but i don't
know what's your story with it i think
it was the eviction you know
yeah didn't it didn't hannigate she rang
a landlord and he had
multiple yep
oh yeah i mean i've been on my youtube
channel there's been
probably hundreds of rent-to-rent deals
done over but yeah hannah on the
eviction did um you've now done it i
know you're also successfully deal
sourcing and that's actually where the
bulk of your money is coming in right
now maybe talk to me a little bit about
that yeah so deals and basically that's
our active income to
put into the rent to rents yeah um we've
been selling since january about dlr2
every single month so one or two deals a
month yeah which is all you need to make
a decent yeah so like um we've been
thinking we've been really slow with
dealson because obviously you see people
doing like three or four every month but
yeah we've been getting about one or two
and um yeah we've been putting that
strain to rent to rents and then getting
the mostly passive income yeah use
managements uh management companies so
then it's mostly passive but you have to
do very little yeah because we have
three rent to rent now we took
everything that we made
we just went yep because we want passive
income exactly right so we're going to
put it straight into
events around where are your other two
restaurants so edinburgh and manchester
so you've got one in edinburgh one in
york one in manchester you're hitting
all these beautiful cities all these
beautiful northern cities um how much
are you making then in total profit now
with the third one that you've just got
up and running um per month in rent to
rents yeah so the the editor has just
got them on [ __ ] yeah about 22 days
so that's gonna be this month's profit
1.3 k amazing
one deal you don't even own yeah can you
most people don't make that much of
properties that they own yeah well
that's what i'm saying to you so one
point three k this month off the aid
number one and is that is that set to be
standard i know with service
accommodation
it varies every month yeah overall what
are your predictions
right it's been a good month this month
yeah yeah yeah yeah
and then manchester that's about for you
talking about 300 to 500. right it's 500
yeah that's in july um and last one was
like 300. so the manchester one's like a
slow dribbler yeah and then it's york
and the number one of the bulk yeah
york's the one that's just
taking it
so you're thinking with all three is it
about 2000 a month roughly yeah if you
if you add a pool or average it out
and what about your deal sourcing how
much profit are you making from from
that yeah so we we calculate that
infinite we've sold anything that's to
do deal so we put into one part um so
we're looking at up 2.7 k
but you'll so you talk about sometimes
three grand sometimes it's five grand
when you're looking at an average of two
yeah so so so a couple grand rent to
rent and then a few grand from your deal
sourcing so if you add it all up
everything that you're making from
property it's it's it's a decent salary
it's about five grand a month when you
put the renter ends in as well yeah and
that and you've done that like
almost immediately you've done that
ridiculous in a matter of just a few
months um from from moving here almost
like you're a financial freedom
challenge i've moved to abu dhabi did
you start from scratch did you all the
money you put into events has that been
all from scratch so basically when we
moved over we had a little bit of money
didn't we um we were a little bit silly
in the uae because obviously before
we're going to be there for a long time
so we were saving less than we could
have it was points
yeah a lot less there was points where i
was saving about a thousand pounds a
month um clean savings and then
i spent most of suits in the summer and
then
and then the golf course uh we literally
just bought a new set of clubs and
everything yeah and then we moved over i
was like we've got no savings left
so we basically spent everything that we
had went on
courses yeah the car the insurance yeah
so when we started like full time in
property i think we had like a couple of
grand yeah we were literally
yeah yeah it wasn't much very all of it
was from deals arsenal and then putting
in two races
um you know you've put like i mean the
academy is 12 grand you've both you've
both joined the academy so you've spent
a lot of money on education
um
good move bad move on your fingers
because we wouldn't be able to do it we
would have been so much slower yeah
we want to know how to sell deals we
want to be able to get around to rents
or not good ones like ended like a usa
event recently anyone can get a rent
around and it's true yeah like uh you
know you need to know how to not pay a
deposit like for y'all we didn't pay a
deposit so i'll save those 800 quid off
the bat yeah um
it's just those little bits that make
you more money and
also save you money for rent to rent as
well yeah
i think when you don't follow it step by
step the mistakes are too costly yeah
the mistakes that you make are going to
be more expensive than paying for the
course in the first week that's true you
guys are going to pay for your education
you're going to pay for your mistakes
and i think i think as well one of the
things alistair says which is which i
think is brilliant he says if someone
said
there's i've got a red service
accommodation deal you need to put
five grand into it and then you'll make
five grand a year you think oh that's
100 return investment you do it but then
if someone says i've got some training
programs where that then people i don't
want to spend money on training but it's
like hang on a minute like you guys for
instance you've spent a lot on the
academy but you've already made it back
yeah yeah and you know you've got five
grand a month coming in every single
month so and you're gonna obviously
massively build on that over the over
the next few months and years so
it's it's mega i mean what what are your
plans moving forward what's what what
what's what's next so
i've been trying to do a lot of training
with alex there uh as well because
obviously he does the speaking yeah i
want to end up being a speaker wow and
helping oh you know kind of setting my
own foundation to help people either do
something similar to this um or just in
uh it's hard to explain um kind of my
local community or trying to help there
as well um because finances doesn't
really get taught yeah people even get a
job in tesco or they'll go and get a job
as a you're a teacher or something like
that um you know
no one really knows about finances or
what you can do in
your like this like runs the rents and
deals and yeah
everyone thinks you should just get by
to let rent out right so you're
passionate about spreading the message
keep making sure people are financially
educated and you're right i mean
you go to school and you don't know
anything about investments or debt good
debt bad debt asset liabilities you
don't know anything so uh so that's
awesome so you want to be able to stop
being shining the light and helping
others
when i was a teacher i was like impact
like maybe like 20 kids a year
and
you know from watching you i was like
well i can do
you know tens of thousands instead
online
online or going to speaking at events
yeah
again speaking in a local community if i
can do that then that's much more
effective yeah than 20 children or 30
children every single year yeah
that's great what about you what's your
strongest reason for doing all this so
i'd say my main reason is family just
when we went out to avid ib it's great
to make that money
but
you're not close enough to family to
actually help them you've got the funds
but you haven't got the time you're not
close enough so
i think for me it's being able to be
close to my family
making money being able to help them um
and helping having the time to help
charities like now that we're
financially free i want to go volunteer
in one of the hospitals near me but i
couldn't have done that
if i wasn't making this money if i was
teaching i didn't have the time to go
and do it yeah that's great oh you guys
are such an awesome couple um what has
it been like working with me in the in
this in the short time that you've been
working with me so far what's it been
like
i'd say it's just this environment
it's like nothing
you can't you can't explain it i met my
friend for breakfast for the day and i
was trying to explain
this environment like the energy that
you have is something else
and when you go to these events
you just leave on such a high
from being around everyone everyone's so
positive everyone honestly wants the
best
for everyone else it's just such a great
environment and since like meeting you
it's just
believing that you can do it yeah yeah i
think if we hadn't when we flew over i
still thought
it's too good to be true it doesn't work
i was a bit skeptical
and then meeting you and everybody else
and seeing people who have done it
it just makes you realize that it is
possible i mean now we're here
to think we were watching winners on a
wednesday videos going i i'd like to be
on that couch okay and now we're here
talking to you it's just crazy
oh that's so cool
yeah these are obviously similar to what
ellen said there with the academy it's
just um
the people you meet on there yeah the
the networking is good
it's so good to have people it's a lot
of careers everyone's trying to hold
each other down because they think that
to build themselves up they have to make
sure everyone else stays down but i
think there's something great about the
world of property investing certainly
within the academy and the space that
we're talking about where everybody
wants everybody to win you know deal
sources are doing business with the
other deal sources rent to rent the
co-labs and you know i think it's great
and it's just i just want to say you
guys have been i know you've got a lot
from the academy but also you've brought
a lot and i really appreciate how much
of an asset you both are to the academy
i appreciate you traveling all the way
down from york for your your busy
service accommodation to come and share
the story of how you've achieved
financial freedom in such a short space
of time from abu dhabi so thank you so
much and look forward to continuing to
work together over the coming months and
years absolutely thank you well thank
you for yeah thank you for having us
welcome awesome so there we go guys that
is ellen and ashley i think you're a
great absolutely fabulous couple if
you're inspired by their story then let
us know by simply hitting the like
button also don't forget to subscribe
the good news is
you don't have to travel
under covered restrictions all the way
from abu dhabi if you're watching this
and you're based in the uk
you have no
excuses okay come on down to the
property investors crash course it is
free so travel down i'll leave a link in
the description where you can book on
for free on the house also don't forget
to subscribe if you're not subscribed
you can do that up here if you want to
watch more videos like this where people
have become financially free as a result
of coming on the property investors
crash course you can check out a whole
playlist of over 100 interviews up here
and i look forward to seeing you next
time
[Music]